Hi there.
I'm Jason Guts and you're listening to
think again.
A big thing podcast
since 2008 big thing has been sharing
the big ideas in little doses from some
of the most creative thinkers around on
the thing against podcast.
We take ourselves out of our comfort
zone.
Surprising my guests and me are hosts
with unexpected interview clips from big
thinks,
archives,
uh,
ideas that we didn't necessarily come
here prepared to discuss today.
I'm so happy to be joined by Professor
Eric Kandel of Columbia University in
the year 2000 he won the Nobel prize in
physiology or medicine for pioneering
work on understanding how memory is
stored in the brain by studying a
particular type of sea snail with a
relatively simple nervous system.
In his recent books,
he's been pioneering in a very different
way trying to bridge the gap between the
quote unquote two cultures of the
sciences and the humanities.
His current book,
reductionism in art and brain science
continues this word looking at the ways
both modern art and science reduced
complex phenomena down into their
component parts to achieve new insights
and effects.
Welcome to think again.
Professor Kendall.
Thank you very much.
I guess maybe we should start with the
cultural divide between the humanities
and the sciences.
I mean this is a very big topic,
but maybe you want to start with a bit
of an overview of how that happened.
Yes.
I mean this was in the late 1950
[inaudible] and early 1960s CP snow
wrote a series of give a series of
lectures and motor series of essays on
the divide between the humanities and
the sciences.
He thought that this was an bridgeable
divide because humanists and scientists
are not only had different aspirations,
different goals,
but use different methodologies.
And the point that I tried to make in
this book,
the overriding theme is that humanistic
aspirations are not unique to people who
called humanists,
but scientists can also have humanistic
aspirations and all in modesty I can say
the,
the study of learning and memory is a
humanistic idea.
We all want to understand who we are
because who we are is in large part
dependent on what we remember about
ourselves and that has a biological
base,
the biological basis memory.
In addition,
not only do scientists have humanistic
goals,
but artists use empirical scientific
experimental methods.
And my book shows several examples of
this.
Jackson pollock taking the canvas off
the wall and putting it on the floor and
flipping on it.
This is a completely new approach to
painting,
right?
If you could give it a little,
a brief overview of what what you mean
by reductionism because the term has
many meanings.
Some of them pejorative,
you're not using it in that way here.
Like maybe you could talk about what
reductionism is and how it,
you know,
broadly it's common to art and science,
right?
Reduction is a miss taking a complex
problem that interests you and taking
one component of that problem and going
into the great depth.
So for example,
on the cover of my book,
I have an image by Rothko who's a color
field painter and he's decided that he
can convey emotions most effectively by
using color.
And he uses stripes of color in many of
his paintings to convey a feeling that
it's almost spiritual.
And as he aged and also became more
depressed,
the colors change became darker.
And the Rothko Chapel,
they're dark browns and blacks and silly
conveys a powerful mood in this way.
So this clearly is a reductionist
approach.
He has a chance of doing many things
besides colors,
pick,
use figuration and addition color,
but it drops out.
Figuration focuses only on color and
simplifies the color pattern and yet we
get a powerful response to it.
And this is a,
yeah,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but the way I'm thinking about it,
the goal of reductionism in science at
least as you describe it in the book
specifically,
I'm using the example of your work with
sea snails.
You know you are trying to understand
the complex phenomenon of memory by
looking at a relatively simple nervous
system,
but your goal is to understand that
phenomenon.
Whereas the artists that you describe
what they're trying to do seems to be
less about understanding maybe then
about getting at some more immediate
experience or provoking some kind of
response in themselves or in the viewer
could,
could you speak to that a bit?
Yes.
I mean you,
you described it perfectly.
Reductionism need not simply solve a
scientific problem,
although in a sense every artist's
solves scientific problems along the
way.
But it may be that of the range of
emotional experiences.
The artists were only focused on some
rather than others in order to go into
it in some depth.
So for example,
I mean the history of art from Giotto to
1852 claude monet was figuration,
the whole idea of art was to deceive the
viewer and to thinking that when they
were looking at a flat surface,
they were in fact seeing a three
dimensional world and the whole autistic
capability critically involved trying to
develop perspectives,
et cetera.
That gives you the sense of three
dimensionality,
modern arts,
reduce that.
Why not accept the fact that we work on
a flat surface and let's do the most we
can with a flat surface and bring out
new stuff.
And what they're driving at though as
you it in the book,
and you quote a number of these artists,
but they seem to be driving at most of
them is trying to get a more immediate
experience of the sublime but,
but not to demystify it in any way and
that I wonder whether that's sort of the
heart of this cultural divide sometimes
between the arts,
the humanities and the sciences that you
know,
science seeks to demystify.
Whereas the,
the arts at least I don't know that they
do.
I don't,
I don't know that they're using
reduction
and as well.
I think you're absolutely right.
I don't think the artists tries to
demystify that is not the purpose of
reduction.
The purpose of reduction is to increase
the mystery.
I mean one of the wonderful things about
abstract painting,
if we look at a de Kooning of we look at
a Jackson pollock is because the
information is often ambiguous.
It forces us to fill in the detail,
and I described this in the book in
terms of top down processing.
We rely on our free association,
our memory,
our previous experience to fill in the
detail of ambiguity.
And that means that you recruit the
beholder,
the participant in the creative act.
This actually goes back to Alice Rigo
and took umbrage and turns.
Chris,
who pointed out that when you and I look
at the same painting,
we see it somewhat differently.
What does that mean?
That each of us is recreating in our own
brain?
The image that we are looking at that is
the beholder undergoes in a very modest
way,
a creative experience that parallels in
a very modest way the creativity of the
artist.
And why is that interesting?
I don't know whether you've had that
experience,
but certainly I find when I have the
most modest creative idea,
it gives me a great deal of pleasure.
And I think one of the things that is so
pleasurable about abstract off for those
people who respond to it is that it
gives you lots of room for your own
creativity.
So now what's interesting though,
with these abstract painters,
and not all the painters that you
described in the book are abstract.
I mean,
chuck close,
you use this abstraction to build up,
you know,
portraits.
But is that in a way they're,
they seem to be seeding some of the,
some of the control of the artist over
to the,
the beholders share like increasingly by
saying absolutely.
Right,
right.
The share is,
has a more prominent feature in abstract
art than it hasn't figured of art.
And this is one reason why some people
don't like abstract on too much work for
them,
but other people who enjoy this get a
lot of satisfaction out of it.
I guess where I was going with that is
that it seems an unusual move for an
artist,
like our stereotype of artists is that
they can be somewhat of control freaks,
you know,
wanting total control over the process
and over how the thing is perceived.
I think
that's definitely true of writers to
some extent,
but for them to make this move of,
you know,
giving more and more over to the viewer
is an interesting move.
I get your point and you're 100% right.
It is only one dimension of it.
I think they all control freaks.
I think that pollock and de Kooning are
perfectionist.
And you're the,
I discussed this one painting that
Rosenberg who it was a superior,
I guess,
professorship here.
Columbia came to visit him and saw this
and said,
you know,
this is a wonderful petty at decoding,
didn't want to release the painting,
didn't think it was ready to go cause
he,
you still felt he could approve it and
he told him this is a masterpiece.
Get it out right now.
So I mean they are very much control
freaks,
but they control freaks in the way they
control Mba and they're controlling,
I guess their own sort of their own
experience,
their own,
right.
Right,
right,
right.
Then and then it's,
then it's up to the viewer.
That's,
that's interesting.
Okay.
Um,
well I think that might be a good moment
for us to transition into the,
uh,
the second part of this.
Yes.
This is,
uh,
this first one is Jan 11,
who's an astrophysicist and the video is
called three visionary scientists who
embraced limitations to have creative
outbursts.
I became interested in this phenomenon
of constraints,
inspiring creative outbursts.
And if you look at the last century,
there were three really profound
examples of that.
I would say the earliest that I found
incredibly interesting was the limit of
the speed of light leading Einstein to
the theory of relativity where a lot of
other scientists wanted to remove the
limit.
They want it to say there is no limit to
the speed of light.
That doesn't make any sense.
That's impossible.
Einstein actually,
despite the word relativity,
adhere to a very strict absolute,
and that absolute was the speed of
light.
He took that to be his guiding
constraint and by sticking to it
rigidly,
he said,
I'll give up anything else but the speed
of light.
And by doing so,
he gave up on the absolute nature of
space and time.
So I mean that's just much harder to let
go of intuitively,
but it was right,
right.
So she's talking about embracing
limitation,
like how limitation can actually push
science forward.
Have you found that to be true in your
own work?
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
in a sense it isn't quite a reductionist
approach,
but it's focusing on one thing to the
exclusion of others in a sense.
And certainly if you look at the history
of go beyond mammies,
do I take a larger problem?
If you look at the explosion and
understanding the biology of life that
came with the discovery of genes by
Mendel and then later on,
but Thomas and Morgan realizing that
genes are on chromosomes and then the
discovery,
the jeans are made out of DNA than a
fabulous watson crick discovery about
the structure of DNA of the gene.
I mean these are all focusing on the
gene to exclusion of carbohydrate
metabolism,
lipid metabolism,
everything else.
Those are secondary processes that
derive from genetic control of cellular
processes.
So I think in a sense,
this is not a universal strategy,
but a common strategy.
Often there are major variables that if
you understand them,
other things will follow more readily.
I guess it was a Karl Popper,
I think it was,
um,
the WHO spoke about paradigm shifts and
how essentially science proceeds by
people laboring in specific trenches for
long periods of time.
And then either you have a visionary who
breaks things open or,
or,
or those limitations of focus end up
leading to breakthroughs.
[inaudible] pump has been very important
in my field.
Uh,
in the following way,
a cop,
Papa felt you can't prove anything in
science.
Where do you can do is disprove.
And that turned out to be a very
important historical insights.
Uh,
there was a guy by the name of Jack
Eccles who was a major,
major person in my field and major
student of synaptic transmission.
And he thought synaptic transmission
between nerve cells was mostly
electrical.
And with time it became clearer and
clearer that this was likely to be
wrong.
And echoes became despondent at that
time,
I think.
I think he was in Australia,
I forget where he was,
but he went to the faculty club and he
bumped into popper and they became
friends and he explained to him why he
was depressed.
And Papa said,
that's ridiculous.
You can't ever prove anything.
All you can do is to disprove it,
go back into the lab and disprove
yourself,
show that you were wrong,
that it's not electrical,
that it must be chemical.
And that's exactly what he did,
I guess.
Yeah.
I guess I would be interested in hearing
kind of as an adjunct to this,
what you know in,
in your field and the work that in the
work that you do on,
on memory and brain science,
what are the intractable problems right
now that people are finding themselves
bumping up against that if they could
solve them,
it would be a major,
you know,
move forward.
What seemed to be the new frontiers
right now for brain science?
We're trying to see,
for example,
what is responsible for the reliability
of memory on the one hand.
And it's extraordinary unreliability and
the other,
um,
you know,
often we have the feeling we remember
something when we don't write a well,
we misremember it.
Uh,
and this is why,
uh,
testimony in is so unreliable.
A single observer,
remembering an event has a finite and
not too small chance of being wrong,
not by being dishonest,
by just misperceiving misremembering,
right.
So memory is not,
you know,
stamping something into a book and you
never have to worry about it.
It's often modified as a result of
subsequent experiences without being
aware of it.
So trying to figure out what controls
that and how we can get a better idea
into the core of the memory process is a
very active part of the field.
That's interesting.
Do you think that that may have
something to do?
I mean,
from a cognitive standpoint that that
may have something to do with kind of
the pragmatics of memory?
Like what,
what it is that we actually need to
remember in order to survive versus what
we don't.
I mean that were,
I don't think it deals with the
pragmatics of memory.
I think it deals with the pragmatics of
the brain.
So,
um,
I remember this conversation for example
we're having right now,
uh,
and it's possible that I'm sitting down
one day listening to a similar
conversation and I may confuse that
second conversation.
At a subsequent time as being part of
the first conversation,
you really,
the initial memory and you often bring
to bear on it some of the subsequent
experiences associated with the second
sitting,
not just the first possibly because
those things are being stored in us.
I mean,
I'm not asking you to speculate on
science that hasn't been done yet,
but possibly because those memories are
stored in similar areas and we're
conserving space or something.
They tried it and it can be activated in
different words.
And also when a memory is recalled,
particularly the first few times it
sensitive to disruption and distortion,
so those things can interfere with the
longterm fidelity of the memory storage.
How does that disruption or distortion
happen?
I mean like so when I'm recalling the
memory,
the first few times it be the disruption
is only in the sense that the memory is
fixed,
but the structures that fix it become
unglued for a second,
for short period of time.
So the memory if perturbed can be
altered.
So if something like,
so let me,
let me put it to you this way.
When you form a memory,
it's a short term.
I mean it doesn't persist,
but if you train repeatedly,
you form a longterm memory and the
longterm it consists of growth of new
synaptic connections and those synaptic
connections require new protein
synthesis doing a certain critical
period that protein synthesis is
sensitive to disruption and you can lose
the growth of new synaptic connections
despite the fact that they've occurred
because the synthesis is not ongoing
after,
while that no longer happens,
but in the early stages of longterm
memory storage,
it's susceptible to disruption and
disruption can come from like other
memories or ambient things happening
around you,
other experiences of the men.
Right.
Interesting.
Okay.
Well I think,
I think on that note,
let's,
uh,
let's move on to the second surprise
clip.
This is Harvard psychologist Susan David
on the psychology of defeating fear,
low self esteem and hate live in the
mind
when we have politicians who are
effectively demagogues,
who are inspiring fear in us,
that fear leads to very particular and
relatively predictable responses.
When we off fearful there is this idea
in psychological research of mortality
salience that when our mortality is
threatened,
when someone says,
Oh,
this group of people is out to get you
and we feel that we are actively being
threatened,
we are more likely to stereotype,
we are more likely to respond to
messages that we hear time and time
again,
even if they are against our values as
somehow making sense to us.
How do we protect ourselves against
this?
Daniel Conaman describes system one
thinking and system two thinking system.
One thinking is the intuitive response
that can sometimes arise out of fear
system two is the deliberate thoughtful
examination of what is this person's
saying?
Is it aligned with how I really want to
be?
When we are able to step back from our
fear,
we are able to come to a place where we
are ultimately protected from the
demagoguery message.
Okay,
so we're talking about demagoguery and
fear and a,
I guess an immediate point of reference
in America in 2016 leaps to all of our
minds immediately.
Yes,
I have have really your experiences like
this.
Oh,
I would like to hear about that.
Yes.
I'm
Jewish and I was born in Vienna,
Austria,
and Myrna was nine years old,
right?
Hitler marched into Austria and was
received by the Viennese in Vienna where
I was living with open arms and
immediately people who have been our
friends turned away from us and
essentially became our enemies.
And that's because Hitler had fantastic
antisemitic propaganda and he got this
propaganda in pod from an earlier
Vinnie's Hitler was in Vienna in 1906
1910 and the mayor of Vienna at that
time was a guy called Carl Louie Vega,
and Lucas was a terrific orator,
a tremendous campaigner.
He wasn't even all that antisemitic.
He had Jewish friends.
He would say,
I determine who was a Jew,
but he had a fantastic way of saying the
reason you don't have any money is
because the Jews are taking it away from
you.
It scared the hell out of people,
particularly those that didn't have
jobs,
convincing them that the Jews,
by charging high prices,
by creating works of art,
that expensive,
et cetera.
Dot.
God knows how many reasons we're
destroying the quality of their life.
So He created this environment of fear
to which people respond to that.
Hitler wrote in my comp,
I learned more from low how to run a
campaign than anybody else.
And fear is of course the traditional
way in which people pilled up opposition
to one force in order to get support for
another.
And it ate.
I found it very hard for the longest
time to understand how people can listen
to Haydn,
Mozart and Beethoven one day and beat up
the juice the next.
Um,
I,
I wonder what that did you know,
for you to you in terms of your thinking
about humans at that early age to see
that transition happen almost overnight.
Like do you,
do you have conscious memories of,
of that?
Of course.
Yeah,
absolutely.
My brother had built this short wave
radio set and we were listening to it as
Hitler unwatched and to Vienna and then
held them plots.
200,000 people came out and cheered him
like mad.
No,
it dominated the scene.
I walked the streets two days later and
a classmate of mine came up to me and
said,
candle,
I'm never to speak to you again.
That was horrible.
Uh,
and,
and they,
you ask yourself the question,
what is it that separates the good guys
from the bad guys?
And you come to the conclusion,
I think the current campaign in the
United States illustrates that,
that every one of us is capable of good
and evil.
Reinhold Niebuhr once said,
the capability of people for good makes
democracy desirable.
That capability for evil mixed democracy
necessary.
That's well said.
And I recently read a book called
machete season and it was about what
happened in Rwanda and it was primarily
based on interviews with these people
who had been just,
you know,
workers,
ordinary people living in Rwanda who
then became the kind of soldiers of this
campaign,
this massacre against their tribal
enemies.
And just this sort of mundanity of the
way in which they described going out
every day to hunt other people.
It was extraordinary.
Yup.
Absolutely.
Hannah Arendt called this the banality
of evil.
Well,
let's a little bit,
I mean,
I was very irritated with her use of
that.
This was an ice man and Jerusalem,
um,
evil is not for now.
And many of the people,
particularly in [inaudible] case,
he was a major force.
He was not a follower.
He was a leader.
Uh,
but he was able to bring many people
along.
No,
that's right.
That's right.
There are those people at the top who
are very conscious and calculating yes.
And aware of what they're doing.
I mean,
I don't know.
I can't,
you know,
I'm not a psychologist,
but I,
so I can't say whether it,
Donald Trump is,
you know,
personally aware or conscious enough of
what he's doing to be considered truly
evil.
But,
uh,
with his followers,
you want to look at it and you want to
say,
these people are crazy.
These people are stupid.
But obviously that's not the case for
all of them.
Obviously.
Obviously our brains are vulnerable to
this kind of manipulation.
I think this is worth the trump movement
is shown,
is you would never think that a movement
like this could succeed in the United
States.
And it's amazing how far it has gone,
although it is clearly fading.
And that is that there were people who
were dissatisfied with certain aspects
of our lifestyle to whom he appeals.
And he does it by phobia of strangers,
you know,
preventing people from coming into the
country,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Do you have any thought,
do you have any thoughts or insights
from your vantage point?
I mean,
of having experienced what you did as a
kid and seeing this happening in America
and now,
uh,
into sort of what would be a better way
to engage the people that are following
trump now?
Like what is America not doing?
I mean,
I know you're not trying to run the
country,
but I'd be
sure I can.
I mean,
I'm so startled by the success.
Um,
I think the case could be stronger and
we'll be stronger if hilary ran a
campaign a little bit better.
And if she had run her life a little bit
better.
I mean,
you know,
she realized that she's interested in
public office and I think the whole
email thing could have been completely
finesse more over this accepting large
sums of money from companies for giving
lectures when she's going to run for
public office and realize the question
is going to rise is she gets a half a
million dollars or whatever she did for
a lecture.
Is she gonna feel beholden to those
people?
You would?
You would think so.
I mean,
you and I of course would never be with
some of the only guys that are half $1
million,
but Hillary Clinton who had does one no.
Yeah.
I mean it's a it that's right.
I mean,
even if she is somehow immune from to
their influences,
it's hard to preserve the illusion of
neutrality.
I think it's essential.
Yeah.
I think she made mistakes and I think
one of the reasons trump is more
successful than it might've been is that
Hillary,
although I much prefer her,
and I think she would probably make a
very good precedent,
um,
did not handle herself in her public
life in an ideal fashion.
She did not handle herself the way Obama
has handled himself,
which I think is extraordinary.
Sure.
But I,
at the same time,
there just seems be so much anger,
so much fear here.
And like I,
it's hard for me to believe that trump
just instilled that in everybody.
I mean,
obviously there were large numbers of
people concerned about immigrants taking
their jobs and you know,
that,
that have these,
well,
I mean,
did you know our country is not perfect.
If you look at the number of people who
have billions and see where taxes they
pay compared to people earning 40,
$50,000 or $80,000,
uh,
it's,
it's amazing.
You know,
there were problems in this country.
Do I complain?
Not too seriously.
I think this is heaven on earth.
I've had a wonderful life here.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I'd like,
I'd like it to remain so for coming
generations.
So hopefully we can avoid trump getting
elected or any repeat thereof because it
just doesn't bode well for,
for our future.
Yeah.
Yup.
I made,
ended up the price of democracy is
constant vigilance.
I mean,
I'm repeating cliches,
but,
right,
right.
Oh,
but this is true.
All right,
so let's move on to the third and final
video.
Yeah.
This is George Muster on the strangeness
of Physics and Telepathy.
The whole progress of physics is to
start with our everyday experience and
to analyze it and look at it and look
for deviations from it.
So the very nature of action,
really all the natural sciences,
but certainly a physics is to really get
away from our experience.
So the things physics comes up with are
just kind of a weird sub atomic
particles.
We can't see them directly at least,
but we know they're there.
We can actually do thought experiments
about the things we do see and deduce
their existence.
So already,
even with just that limited an example,
we've gone intra beyond our direct
experience in a hundred years ago or so,
people doubted the existence of atoms,
a lot of loan sub atomic particles,
nonlocality spooky action at a distance
is very much in that,
in that mold.
It's taking this yet further away from
our experience and therefore we expect
it to be weird.
It shouldn't be weird.
That's why physics is flooded.
And as other scientists have said,
you would expect it.
In fact,
if the theory isn't weird,
you kind of doubt it cause you worry
that your own biases are intruding into
the,
into the theory and causing you to think
the world is a certain way when you're
not listening to the way the world
actually is.
So weirdnesses in a sense a test of a
theory.
I mean I do,
I blog actually,
but not completely agree with it.
Uh,
I don't think physics necessarily has to
be weird and did weirdness.
Sydney's not a test of the reliability
of it
theory,
but certainly it deals with phenomenon
that we do not intuitively think about
all the time or at least people outside
of physics.
I'm thinking about it.
And it deals with many that are
invisible,
have to be inferred.
And some day biology will reach that
level.
At the moment,
that's not the case.
Uh,
biology doesn't that all deal with
things that are weird?
I mean it's some weird things come out
of it,
but he tries to explain,
you know,
living processes that make intuitive
sense and we want to understand them in
a more profound when you can you say
more about what you mean by Sunday
biology make,
make out there.
Why,
why would that happen?
Well,
I think we probably want to understand
things on a deeper level right now.
If we understand that the level of of
molecules,
we think we're making a great deal of
progress,
but we may want to make it,
you know,
on an even more profound level on the
level of electron movement or something
like that.
We seen this all the time.
As a matter of fact take theory,
which has such an important role in
physics.
It didn't have an important role in
biology for the longest time.
Um,
when I came along there was a fair
amount of theory going on,
but it was mostly Malarkey,
right?
Because you can make a theory about
anything.
You want to have a theory about memory.
I give you a five tiers of our memory.
You know,
people were coming up with theories,
but they were not testing them.
Right?
This is changed.
Now.
Series had a major comeback in the last
15 years.
This was true for a long time in physics
as well,
right?
I mean they had all these theories that
they weren't able to test without the
particle reactors and so on.
And so,
so from the standpoint of lay people,
it was like,
what on earth are they talking about?
It's true,
but,
but in brain science it was a little bit
different because they could test it,
but they didn't think of doing it.
They didn't think it was necessary.
I see.
To test the theory,
but the fact is we can develop a theory
for anything unless you say,
now this is a prediction.
Let's run an experiment to test that
prediction,
which is what's going on right now.
It does brand science.
You talked a little bit about your book
in your book about how brain science and
psychology have somewhat merged in.
Oh,
that Ronnie has impact on one another.
And again,
again,
this is an area in which,
um,
people outside of psychology,
even in the early stages,
psychologists thought that these
primitive guys from brain science,
when I eat us up,
they want to swallow the fear.
And that's not,
you cannot do biology of the mind
without being a psychologist.
I mean psychologist described many of
the obvious central phenomenon,
a classical conditioning perception
sensation.
All of these things were studied in very
reliable ways in psychophysical terms.
And we we now want to do is add the
biology to it and give it a new depth
and new level of understanding.
It's a beautiful case of coming
together.
In fact,
I would go further than this.
Uh,
I would say there had been a sequence of
mergers first it was a major between
cognitive psychology and brain biology,
sort of a new biology of mind.
But at the same time this was occurring,
it was watson and Crick and,
and all these people are coming along
developing molecular biology.
And so the approaches of molecular
biology,
cloning,
gene sequencing,
them figuring out their function through
mutations became applicable to the
brain.
So we can now test many of these ideas
with powerful molecular approaches.
Knock out this gene,
get rid of this particular protein.
So this put brain science and a
completely new level.
It's interesting,
I mean going back to the test case of
psychology and brain science though I,
that is kind of a beautiful model I
suppose for the reconciliation of the
sciences and the humanities in a way
because,
well,
Secretary Collins,
you,
in all fairness,
by the time we got around to it was no
longer part of the humanities and
science as part of the management.
I mean it is a humanistic discipline,
but psychology at that time,
cognitive psychology was empirical out
laboratory tests,
experimental discipline.
Right,
right,
right.
No,
I guess I'm,
I guess I'm thinking of like theory of
personality and I'll do something else.
The psychodynamics of it that still
soft.
In fact,
I,
you know,
my,
I was interested in psychoanalysis.
I wanted to become an analyst at one
point and I'm glad I didn't go that
direction because psychoanalysis is
dying and one of the reasons this dying
is it has not become empirical.
Right.
And yet we do have these
big questions,
you know about like about meaning
identity,
what it means to live a good and
authentic tic
life,
some of which are absolutely and,
and you can ask him,
there was a guy called Aaron Beck who
developed cognitive behavioral
psychology.
I don't know whether you know this is
about it.
He was interested in testing one of
Freud's ideas.
Freud had the idea that people who are
depressed or angry,
they first express the anger toward
others.
Then you feel guilty about this.
Then they internalize it,
feel angry with themselves and that
caused the depression.
So Aaron Beck's what he would test this
and he would test it by using the royal
road to the unconscious,
which is dreaming.
So listen to the dream life is with
depressed patients and did an all sound
as if this was the problem with them.
What they all sounded like is that they
had a low image of themselves.
He,
this guy was a famous radio interviewer
and he thought of himself as being,
you know,
so,
so a guy was very successful in
business,
thought it was a failure at home.
The low image.
And as he began to address himself to
this issue of low image saying,
you know,
why do you think you'd like this,
Joe?
Look,
your family really enjoys you and
appreciates you.
He began to alters behavior and
cognitive behavior therapy developed.
So what Aaron Beck did is to write a
cookbook so you and I could do the same
thing I see.
And he asked other people to do this and
they were able to get the same results.
And then he did a prayer call,
outcome studies with controls showing
that mild and moderate depression,
uh,
significantly helped by cognitive
behavior therapy.
Severe,
not so much,
but synergistic with,
we worked very well.
So you can take these concepts and make
them scientific.
It just hasn't happened by and large in
psychoanalysis.
We don't know if it works under what
circumstances and how it works.
And that's got to come if it's going to
survive at all.
Okay.
Well,
Eric,
handle it has been wonderful talking to
you today.
Thank you so much,
uh,
for,
for spending your time on this show.
This has been a lot of fun.
And,
and to our audience,
I would strongly recommend professor
Kendall's new book reductionism in art
and brain science.
It is fascinating,
beautifully written.
The science has explained incredibly
clearly and it's full of gorgeous
reproductions of modern paintings.
Thank you so much for your time,
Professor Kendall.
Oh,
thank you for inviting me.
This is very enjoyable for me.
Sit for this week's episode of think
again,
I've been talking lately on this show to
a lot of artists and writers and it's
really refreshing to speak to a
scientist,
especially one who has lived through so
many of the major developments in the
past century in science and art and has
so much to say about them.
I hope you enjoyed that conversation as
much as I did and we have lots of
amazing things lined up this fall.
It's going to be a really,
really interesting fall.
I'm going on a brief and much needed
vacation,
but the show will be here and I hope to
see you back here next week.